WIL WILLIS: Gentlemen, your
(inaudible) spears look deadly.
So let's find out if they
really are in our weapons test.
Up first-- the kill test.
Doug?
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
I will take your Zande spear
and deliver killing blows
on this ballistics stomach.
Drew, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's make those
intestines out-testines.
All right, let's do that.
I like that.
DREW (VOICEOVER): Right now,
I'm about to hear Doug say,
it will kill.
And that's the only
thing I'm here for.
To help me out today, please
welcome back RJ Marcaida.
He will have the pleasure of
wielding your Zande spear.
All right, Drew.
It feels very good in the hand.
It lacerates deep when we
thrust into the chest cavity,
into the heart.
On its way out, not only does
it take some skin with it,
but it also took out some ribs.
Your tines right here
from the side entry--
the spear went all the way
through, and on its way out,
it took everything
that was in its path.
But there is one issue.
As you can see, your tip
right here broke off.
But other than that, this
is a weapon that is deadly.
And it will kill.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Jason, your turn.
You ready?
- I know it'll cut.
It bit me four times making it.
I'm thinking it's going
to wreck this thing's day.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Jason.
The balance of your
weapon feels good.
When it penetrated into the
chest cavity, it hit a rib
and broke it in half.
Got into the heart, and there
was no edge damage on your tip.
All these hooks
right here did what
it's supposed to do-- into the
abdomen, ripped everything up.
Even the barb.
And the beautiful thing
about this is it will kill.
That's what I wanted to hear.
Say hello to my
little friend here.
Today, we're going to
test the overall strength
and construction of
your Zande spears by--
well, we're going to fire
'em out of this cannon
into this wood block wall.
Now, I'm not
concerned about what
your spears do to the wall.
I want to see how well your
spears survive the wall.
Drew, you're up first.
You ready?
No.
Well, we're
gonna do it anyway.
Let's do it.
I don't even know what to think.
This thing is gonna be launched.
I'm scared.
That worked really well, Drew.
Despite the fact that you did
lose a little bit of your tip
in the kill test,
didn't have any effect
going into that block wall.
Matter of fact, you sunk
all the way down here.
Very impressive.
Your shaft is fine.
Nothing loosened
up, nothing cracked.
Your spear head is still solid.
Overall, survived.
Very good.
Thank you.
So Jason, what you thinking?
Thinking, let's
make splinters.
I'm a little bit worried
they're gonna shoot this thing
at a wall, and it could break.
We don't want that.
J NEILSON: That's a problem.
Oh god, no.
I'm seeing it hang up I'm bit
on the barrel, and my heart
just absolutely sinks.
Jason, we've got
a big problem here.
The parameters that we
set for these weapons
are for testing purposes.
Because your blade didn't meet
the inch and a half parameter
with a circular
cross-section, we cannot fit
the shaft of your
weapon down the barrel
of our testing apparatus here.
And because we can't
test it evenly and fairly
with Drew's blade, I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
This was absolutely
worst-case scenario.
Neither Drew nor I wanted
to see either of us going
out on something like this.
I was over those
dimensions 100 times,
and apparently somewhere
in there, there was
one little spot that I missed.